et maintenant mesdames messieurs
on y est non ma vie romancée
savoir non non non et un moral quand
même service et pas c'est pas la
première fois qu'on se le dire est la
dernière ni la dernière à la résume
toutes nos vies un magnétoscope ou du
boeuf d'amour de doucement ma fille
pleure pas le nord tiens ils s'en lavent
oui alors c'est quoi ces c'est vraiment
la fin d'émission ouais c'est vrai mais
je
suis désolé plusieurs toits du genou en
août là ouais on encore le canapé ne
peuvent s'épanouir et métiers du vin
thierry prend ta caméra le site initial
avant la foa et aca oui bon bah écoute 1
on va s'asseoir feront pas
un
synthétique la gra double g il ya eu
aussi un fan tout le monde en parle
serge voilà c'est fini bien sûr été dans
des bus jusqu'à maintenant jean loubat
père va nous faire un cadeau formidable
parce que chaque fois que j'aurai une
émission jeu mais voilà c'est fini bravo
on espère prête et là ce soir pour la
première fois jean louis van gaal
chanteur après
[Applaudissements]
voilà
c'est fini on va pas dire au revoir
comme sur le quai d'une gare je dis
seulement bonjour et fais gaffe à
l'amour
voilà
6 mai
aujourd'hui ou demain c'est le moment où
tu te mets peut-être après demain tu
nous
retrouvera
[Musique]
car c'est fini
qu'est ce que vous attendez au vermont
ici
merci toujours là quand on se fait virer
on continue avec le beaver de laurent
baffie
s'est passé beaucoup de choses ont
changé des kurdes et puisse imaginer que
le transmet s'éviter
alors en cette saison encore tu as
prouvé que tu étais le meilleur sniper
du monde du magnéto serge ce monde là je
rampais pour ceux qui ne seraient pas le
19 mai 2016 pendant un match de foot
amical à cannes vous avez fait un arrêt
cardiaque heureusement parmi les joueurs
il y avait des gens qui savaient faire
un massage cardiaque
c'est ce qui vous a sauvé vous vous
rendez compte que vous avez joué au foot
avec baffie il vous aurait touché les
couilles je connais hélas hélas il y
aurait une mort subite est là il y
aurait eu moins je n'aurais pas lâcher
alors malgré le fait que tu aies faire
un centre trop long
non le grand ennemi des lits c'est le
frelon asiatique
le frelon asiatique
tu vois ce sujet de l'espionnage que je
suis à cran les frelons asiatiques qui
sont vraiment ils sont tous dans le
troisième pour l'instant
m6 mama m'a fait confiance m'a fait
confiance sur beaucoup de projets oui
mais tu es très à l'aise je sais
exactement où je mets les pieds tu fais
pas de centre trop long tube bien cadré
il ça vous fait rire la bcc c'est
carrément quel âge 70 voilà bah tu lui
fais pas
franchement tu fais 68 ans
maximum des fois il fait 69
jugent fait pas dit bonjour
là d'où je viens nous avons les parties
génitales dans la main
[Applaudissements]
tous
vient alors cette année on a eu droit
oui et des 56 états voulaient non parce
qu'on a eu tout un family office
à une telle réputation que lorsqu'une
jeune femme bien dans l'émission elle
vient auparavant
mais non plus depuis six ans il serait
capable de relever le dessus alors oui
as tu verras comme un mur et là je suis
très différents
je crois que l'année prochaine je vais
faire toutes les émissions
[Applaudissements]
merci oui tu vois c'est formidable et
pénales ta mère oui samedi dans ce qu'on
appelle une vieille [ __ ]
c'est la fête des mères on peut alors on
va te calmer petit connard
pardon ne m'en excuse moi
et après la mère aurait eu droit aux
fils de jo
avec les deux personnages en fait elle a
envie alors pas envie de baiser avec les
deux quoi l'on reconnaît on
la filiation
pas du tout comme talent fou et éduquer
mon temps après elles seront dès jeudi d
horreur c'est ouais c'est pas faute
voilà très bien voilà populaire
[Musique]
mais
du coup tu cherche du boulot là oui
c'est le mot play j'ai vu je tiens à
rajouter pour les enfants mais oui j'ai
vu que j'allais poster des tweets
d'ailleurs pour proposer des services
saiper plus très jeunes cherchent poste
directeur de chaîne pour pouvoir virer à
mon tour des sexagénaires blanc urgent
qu aux familles
et hu a proposé le 6 à delphine ernotte
c'est vraiment emplit l'âme cherche un
remplaçant à thierry beccaro un hashtag
oui bah tu as plus de mots douteux
des armes en panne pour te vendre en
fait tu aurais pu utiliser le sondage
opinionway qui fait désigne comme le
meilleur chroniqueur de france avec nos
tâches à polony d'ailleurs regarde là
laurent baffie trêve natacha polony 13
c'est mieux que la france est soumise
ce que très positif dans tout ça c'est
que laurent a décidé de remonter sur
scène la revente à da alors sept
dernières années il avait consacré son
talent à l'écriture à la mise en scène
toc toc par exemple se joue dans le
monde entier en belgique au brésil en
ouvre la 10e mn en moldavie et on voit
la fiche moldaves du spectacle de
laurent et là ça se joue encore et
d'issues encore est déçu de ce genre
l'argentine il ya aussi eu la très jolie
trilogie au splendid cette année c'est
énorme avec trois petites pièces l'une
après l'autre ma soeur est une [ __ ]
lafarge a une grosse [ __ ]
j'ai baissé ma mère est extradé peuvent
fedora écrit ça aujourd'hui c'est du
feydeau 2.0 célia il ya le délire de
feydeau et en même temps avec l'humour
de laurent c'est extraordinaire
va remonter sur scène oui tout seul
alors ça s'appelle laurent baffie se
pose des questions alors la fiche est
plutôt soft on faisait partie qui a fait
la file quand on la voit de loin mais
quand on zoome voilà c'est quand même
autre chose en bois on voit des bides de
lapin qui copulent il ya des questions
un peu je me pose des questions dans
tous les domaines ça peut être des
questions c'est d'ordre sexuel ou
philosophiques ou alors tu as des
questions formidable est-ce que les
sourds klaxons le jour de leur mariage
alors c'est des questions que vois je me
pose mais que personne ne se pose jamais
pourquoi quand je rêve que je baise je
me réveille trop tôt et quand je rêve
que je pige dans l'oeil trop tard
autre point positif
les vieux films sur les points positifs
tu as été un soutien du parti animal oui
pendant les élections européennes
t'as pas été candidat sinon on aurait
été obligé d'annuler sa participation à
l'émission mais vous avez fait 2,4 pour
cent il ya près de cinq cent mille fois
bien c'est plus que lui dit de monsieur
lagarde et ses plus que le pcf de
monsieur brossard au fait ces gens très
investi et pourtant il aurait pu faire
beaucoup plus parce que c'était bien de
trouver un bulletin du parti animalistes
un laurent tient toujours aimé les
animaux et là on voit ton chat
il ya un truc qui coup de chance mais
bon
on y arrive c'est la partie négative du
bilan
[Musique]
problème si tu passes tes nuits sur
internet acheter des merdes
leboncoin effet dans le cher tu adores
avère conclu
et je m'amuse à deviner le prix que ça
va faire et les estimations sont souvent
très bonne et pourquoi tu demande pas à
sophie davant de t'engager à la rentrée
bah non mais moi j'ai je vais écrire des
des pièges et des pièces d'avenches mais
si les gens d'affaires les suites des
clefs de bagnole c'est pas ça fait cher
le drame
d'accord ce ouattara tel succès mondial
par le 2 quand même et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
y mettez un pouce bleus